director Quentin Tarantino faces new
criticism for controversial comments he
made during an old radio interview that
just resurfaced in 2003 Tarantino
defended fellow director Roman Polanski
who pled guilty to unlawful sex with a
13 year old in 1977 the victim said she
was drugged and raped
Jericka Duncan has the victim's reaction
to Tarantino's comments streak of good
morning good morning now this audio
surfaced just after Tarantino defended
himself for persuading actress uma
Thurman to perform a stunt that left her
badly injured some 15 years ago well in
this radio interview Tarantino
repeatedly appears to fault Polanski's
young victim I don't care what Quentin
Tarantino thinks I know what the truth
is he was wrong 54 year old Samantha
gamer was just 13 when Roman Polanski
offered to take these photos of her for
modeling shoot about three weeks later
she says the then 43 year old Polanski
gave her alcohol and a quaalude before
raping her in a 2003 radio interview
with Howard Stern that surfaced Monday
director Quentin Tarantino defended
Polanski I don't think it's right I
don't believe it I mean that at 13 not
for these thirteen-year-old party girls
Tarantino repeatedly argues that the
girl was complicit in China with a 13
year old girl you're in a grown man you
know that that's wrong because I'm not
what she was down with it people have
been saying what he said and worse since
I was 13 so I always had to deal with it
Tarantino has recently apologized for
his apparent mistreatment of actress uma
Thurman on the set of their movie Kill
Bill and for largely ignoring Harvey
Weinstein's pattern of alleged sexual
abuse Jezebel was tipped off to the
Howard Stern audio by a reader I think
what surprised me was just how cavalier
Tarantino was being and I think we
definitely see the hypocrisy in this
apologia that's happening now guy mur
says she's heartened that more people
are listening to victims in the wake of
the me2 movement I think me too is
a good thing where we could like have
solidarity for each other the shoes have
been on the other foot now where I'm
shown sympathy and Romans the monster
Polanski fled to France in the late
1970s his lawyer tells CBS News Polanski
regrets his actions and has apologized
to Daimler and he believes Tarantino's
comments represent a misunderstanding of
Polanski's conduct Tarantino has not
responded to our requests for comment
and this is a case where I think he
should have just stayed away from that
exactly right and and I know it was done
many years ago but there's just no
excuse to say what he said about a 13
year old girl no 13 year old girl is
that mature it knows what they're doing
Thank You Jerrica